Katie how are you still alive that
quarantined myself for everyone's safety
you're lying to us what did you do to me
you got to think about the sick of CSI
this cash the worry doesn't add up
get in there freak
along with
we all are in here brother you see Iran
you're not alone
welcome to Metta max and who are you my
name's Martin there's lightning coming
and when it gets here I promise it will
best place to be is in the eye of the
storm with me thank you
please out here I'm kicking your butt
come on man get up
I'm the green arrow yeah I'll say
hey everybody is Charlie we got brand
new flash footage to break down and a
brand new crossover trailer in a deleted
scene from last night's episode teasing
weather wizard putting a new team of
rows together so there's a new brand of
the flash ring giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
a flash related comments on the video
I'll name a new winner at the end of
this so we'll talk about the flash
footage specifically because we're
building towards the hundredth episode
in a couple weeks then I'll talk about
the crossover footage the trailer the
Icicle cometh is obviously a reference
to the Iceman Cometh confirming what we
all suspected Caitlin's father is going
to be the Icicle of the TV show so there
are a couple different versions of
icicle in the comics there's icicle
senior and icicle jr. most people know
icicle jr. even if you're a big comic
book reader the original version of
icicle is like a Silver Age flash
villain he had a cold gun what they did
is is when they wanted the younger
version of the character his son to take
over and take the mantle the way they
explained his powers is it the original
version of icicle his father was exposed
to the chemicals from his cold gun for
so long that it altered his genetics and
he passed his cold liked abilities onto
his son when he was born
sort of like a male version of killer
frost but he mostly appeared in non
flash titles which is kind of weird
because the original version of icicle
did fight the flash every once in a
while but technically they did not
originate inside flash comic books but
the way they're explaining this and the
trailer is it seems like maybe he was
experimenting on something and then that
was passed on to Caitlin when she was
born maybe it'll be some version of that
because you see all those flashbacks
with his goddess of the north that he
was drawing sketches up it winds up
being Caitlin as a child so they might
just be combining a couple of comic book
origin stories to form the TV show's
origin story for their family but the
way they talk about it and then the
trailer Barry says think about it like a
CSI this guy's story doesn't add up the
way they cut the footage is kind of
misleading because there's a scene where
Cisco is calling someone out as a fraud
that's probably going to be Sherlock
wells because he has that really
questionable accent is really hard to
understand if you don't rewatch the
episode once or twice but there's been
all these weird things that he's done
like he broke their transport device
that they use to open wormholes like
remember when they needed it to save
Barry in last night's episode he's like
you know accidentally broke it because
he was doing who-knows-what with it like
why did he need the wormhole device to
pour it around where was he trying to go
so it's one of those episodes where they
play up the mystery thriller aspect
where you don't totally know if the
character is gonna wind up being evil or
if they're being a good character but
the fact that icicle is such a big
villain in the comics makes it seem like
they will Bend him that way eventually
so think about it this way there was
actually somebody watching Kaitlyn on a
bank of monitors after I think the first
or second episode where she started to
unravel all the clues and have her own
little sherlock montage the technology
that her father has at this special
black ops site that looks like it's in
the Arctic somewhere because she's
banging on the door and there's snow
everywhere it just seems like he's been
using very advanced technology to watch
over her for the last couple of seasons
like it'll be one of those situations
where he's like I wanted to reach out to
you but I didn't know how but secretly
something else is going on there's
probably some special reason why he
needs her help something about the way
her powers work or something like that
and it all just seems like the path to
her learning to control her killer frost
abilities the way they explain it on the
TV show is that she never lost her
powers like just because she lost all
the dark matter in her body
she's genetically a metahuman she was
born that way
so remember there are a couple
metahumans that we've met over the
course of the series that have had
powers before the particle accelerator
exploded in season one so it all just
comes back to whatever research he was
doing which is probably the cause of his
accident here which is turning him into
sort of like a human icicle but if
you've seen the comic book drawings of
what his character looks like he's just
turning into a version of that you look
at some of the hard lines on his face
here and it just looks like textbook
villain in the making because you look
at the flash here in Nora and they're
getting knocked back it looks like the
cold in this environment here is
stopping him from using his abilities or
it's suppressing them somehow
remember how killer frost powers work
it's probably the same thing with icicle
so she's sort of like a heat vampire in
the flash is like a heat battery he
generates all that lightning so the more
she sucks out of Barry the more powerful
she gets maybe it's the same situation
with her father so like the flashes run
in because they've tried to stop him
from doing something and they just get
stopped dead in their tracks so they
just let you know that things are gonna
go off the rails pretty quickly but
it'll be really exciting to see how big
of a
he is on the show because Secada right
now is still supposed to be the big bat
the producers explained there's gonna be
three separate story arcs this season
cicada was obviously the first big one
they tease this might be the next one so
I'll be interested to see what the third
story arc ends up being if they bring
her back around to cicada or if another
villain surfaces or they wind up
combining a couple things the deleted
scene that everybody was freaking out
about is just a rag doll from the end of
last night's episode getting thrown in
the metahuman wing of iron Heights
prison where the wizard speaking to him
from one of the other side of this house
saying that he's basically planning on
breaking out he's forming a squad you
best join up because that's the safest
place to be in the eye of the storm
there were a couple people that were
confused about what was going on with
this scene he's just implying that he's
going to reform a new team of rogues in
ragdoll is gonna be a part of that but
remember in the back half of the season
there's gonna be a Grodd
king shark team-up episode so I don't
know if they're gonna tease them in this
they might just wait till we get to the
later episodes to tease that so what's
happening in the next couple of weeks is
that next week we have the Icicle
episode where we get Caitlyn's father
and we probably find out what's going on
with Sherlock then the week after that
the episode is titled oh come all ye
faithful which is their Christmas
reference making it seem like it's going
to be a weather wizard episode that's
probably when they break out of iron
Heights and you have a big Rogues team
up against Barry but the week after that
is going to be the 100th episode where
zoom comes back because Tony Todd the
actor that does the voice for zoom
confirmed he was coming back with plural
other evil speedsters that want a piece
of Barry I don't want to say that
confirms reverse-flash but how many evil
speedsters have we had on the TV show
and if it's an anniversary episode and
it's gonna have crazy comic-book Easter
eggs for lovers of the flash comics then
it'll probably be whatever new version
of eobard thawne and whatever face he's
going to be wearing going forward on the
TV show the week after that is going to
be the crossover episode so obviously
the crossover isn't going to be
happening for a while so there's gonna
be way more trailers for that we still
haven't seen a whole lot of characters
we haven't seen Superman yet we haven't
seen the monitor we haven't seen footage
of black suit Superman or any of the
real plot really just the big twist the
Freaky Friday oh my god I'm in Oliver's
life what's going on here so obviously
the new
is just Barry getting the Oliver trailer
that we did a video for a couple days
ago so I was talking about how Oliver
wakes up in Barry's bed like what the
hell is going on here why is his wife
kissing me I'm glad they didn't do the
exact same thing with him waking up in
Felicity's bed
they actually have him waking up in the
middle of a fight with Diggle and he
somehow knows how to use all the martial
arts abilities that Oliver has like he
reacts instantly and in a surprise like
wait a minute how did I do that the cool
thing about that is that it also
confirms that the same thing will happen
to Stephen amell's Oliver version of the
flash when he tries to use his powers
hopefully in the next trailer I'm hoping
the next teaser that we get is Oliver in
the flash costume using his flash
abilities if they don't go for a
full-blown plot trailer with all the
other characters in it what'll happen is
they drop new Aquaman footage I'll do a
video for that next so it should post in
the next couple of hours there's so much
stuff to drop this week so I'll try to
get it out as fast as possible
congratulations
Chim the fan gaming you're the giveaway
winner from my last big DC video please
email me on the about page of my channel
so I can get your contact details click
here for my flash episode and click here
for that other flash arrow crossover
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome see you guys
tonight